i was that karen i was i was a karen
i was a karen who basically said but
what about all lives matter
stasi schroeder speaks out for the first
time since she was fired from
vanderpump rules people expected me to
just
understand everything immediately and
things like that
take time and i felt like it would be
better
for me to take the time to get a greater
understanding of everything and the
issues
before i opened my mouth bravo cut ties
with the reality star back
in june after some past racially
insensitive remarks
resurfaced amid the black lives matter
protests
and on thursday she opened up about the
whole thing
on the tamron hall show revealing it's
been tough
knowing that people think of her as a
racist that has been the hardest part of
all it should be
that is that is that is absolutely the
hardest part just going out to
a restaurant or going to the grocery
store and wondering if that's what
people
think i don't have hate in my heart but
i've recognized that
i i wasn't anti-racist i wasn't
and that's something i've been learning
throughout all this
the network's decision to fire the 32
year old also came just days after
former sur staffer faith stowers
revealed during an insta live that
stassi and kristen doughty
attempted to report her to the police
for a crime she didn't commit in 2018.
let me ask you this how did you feel
when you heard when you first heard
stassi
saying on that podcast the things that
her and kristen had done and the fact
that they
tried to get you arrested for something
you did not do
they were trying to pretty much destroy
me um
especially dealing with the cops because
i i have a
i have kind of a fear of police
um enforcement because of all the things
that's happening jax carl went missing
out of his home
they said that i was the person that
went into his home
and did grand theft auto like i i went
and broke into his home he stole his car
so
they said so much that it was it was
hard to take in and i was really numb at
that moment because
it was so it sounded like a movie um a
really bad movie
while both stassi and kristen publicly
apologized to faith
bravo opted not to bring them back for
season nine
i i think it's it's sad really
what happened because i do think that
people can learn from their mistakes
and i'm all about that when eti caught
up with lisa vanderpump in
august she said she would have given
stassi and kristen
a second chance of course we do know
that we're in this
you know momentum of really people kind
of standing up for what's right and i'm
all about that and embracing that
and i do believe in zero tolerance for
that but i also believe
that you can come back from that and
you're young and you can learn from it
to me i would like to see them you know
go on
but but really have a better
understanding
of where they went wrong but i
understand why bravo did it
it was it was totally inappropriate
stassi's co-star katie maloney
also opened up to et just last week
about how her friends were handling it
all
imagine being on a show for almost a
decade
and then it's just done so i mean yeah
it was
it was hard for a while but i think
they're just trying to focus
on you know the future and what that
looks like for them and
trying to stay positive and not look
back they're
taking it in stride and definitely you
know
holding themselves accountable the
future of the show is currently in limbo
in the wake of the firings
any chance you'll return to vanderpump
rules no
i think that that ship has sailed stasi
actually explained how she's holding
herself accountable
meeting with a diversity coach on zoom
once a week
and stassi who is five months pregnant
with her first child with her fiance
beau clark
says she wants to be better for her
daughter i want to be a better person
i'm pregnant and i want my daughter to
be proud of me
and i want to be a part of the solution
i've been a part of the problem for
years now
and i i've recognized that
and that's why i say i don't feel like
i'm
a victim of cancer culture people want
me to be mad at it and i'm not i needed
it
i needed that